okay so like most of the world I went to
see Captain Marvel this weekend I went
on Friday and after a lifetime of
referencing the movies the movies
referenced me as I was sitting there
from spoilers if you haven't seen
Captain Marvel yet it's I got to tell
you what happens there to tell you what
happened in the movie Captain Marvel
herself is on top of the train then
blasts into a trench looking for the
scroll scrolls who could change their
appearance so she's looking at everybody
on the train because the scroll could be
anybody could be me could be you so you
hear a guy you're a voice very
unmistakable voice and then you see
somebody on the train with like a book
in front of their faces looks like he
closer it's a script you get closer to
the script you see that it's the the
title treatment font to the movie
Mallrats
and it says by Kevin Smith on it so you
know I I went apeshit I was just [ __ ]
profoundly moved it was Stan sitting
there reading the Mallrats script and
reciting the line over and over like he
was rehearsing going trust me true
believer
trust me true believer
it was everything mind you this was
after I've watched you know the opening
of the movie whom the Marvel Studios
logo was all staying all the time but to
be sitting there you know as I have so
often throughout the course of my life
in a dark movie theater usually next to
somebody I like really liked or loved in
this case was my wife and to you know
see my friend who's no longer with us in
a cameo was thrilling enough to see that
cameo in which Stan was playing himself
getting ready to be in my movie back in
nineteen
95 was like so I'm gonna keep it under
control I'm gonna tell you how I found
out about it cuz I knew before I got to
the theater I got a phone call a couple
months back after Stan passed away from
the great Kevin Feige over at Marvel
Studios and naturally [ __ ] Kevin Feige
calls hello
pick up the phone right away so Kevin
was like I read your Stan thinks I put
up a Instagram post after Stan passed
and he's like and I heard the podcast
because we didn't episode of fat man I'm
Batman me and Mark Barnard at scum and
villainy where were you Lajoie Stan this
is before we did the recent excelsior
event with Legion em at the Grauman's at
the Chinese Theatre TLC TCL Chinese
Theatre so we were talking about how
bummed we were that Stan had passed and
then Kevin goes well I'm calling you
with a very specific reason
that's alright what's up and he goes I
got to tell you this but you can't tell
anybody in order for me to go forward I
got to tell you
Stan's cameo and Captain Marvel and I
was like oh ok like you know that's [ __ ]
now I was getting information early and
stuff so he goes the Captain Marvel is
on the train he explains the whole thing
and he says then there's Stan he's
reading the script Mallrats
and you know I cried on the phone with
him I was like you [ __ ] [ __ ] me
he's going yeah that's that was the
cameo he goes now we shot his cameo for
Avengers before this this cameo they had
done for Captain Marvel this was when
Stan was on his weaker side it was only
a few months before he passed
so they Kevin asked me he's going like
did you have alternate takes on Mallrats
of him doing his lines because you know
the day we shot him he was kind of
physically weakened and so the voice
wasn't quite there so I said I mean I
don't have them but we did you know like
the had multiple takes it's not like he
was a one-take wonder and stuff so there
are multiple takes of them somewhere
doing those lines if you call Universal
they might be able to track it down so
when he told me like I remember one of
my friends was just like Kevin Feige
called you did you think he was gonna
ask you to direct a movie and I was like
no isn't that weird
that's how little I think of myself as a
filmmaker is that dude called and the
first thing went through my head was
like I gotta get him on a [ __ ]
podcast like he's my white whale are you
kidding me I could do hours with Kevin
[ __ ] foggy man he's one of my
favorite storytellers on the planet and
I don't say that cuz I'm like I want a
[ __ ] job at Marvel I like watching
those movies making them looks like it
would be a real pain mask
but that referencing me in a Marvel
movie like these [ __ ] movies means so
much to me it's nuts
really is it's probably [ __ ] sad how
much they mean to me to see you know
stand sitting there on the train
rehearsing for mine so the flick I made
like 24 [ __ ] years ago man like you
know because the movie set in 1995 it
was everything like turned to my wife
and I was like I could die now oh shut
up I was like no I won't and one day I
will die I was so happy like years ago
because I'd always loved him thought I
was so cool
I put Stan Lee in a movie and then 24
years later if you returned the favor
and other people did as well
I know it wasn't just Stan but Stan said
the words and that was everything my big
thanks to Kevin Feige I know he's the
engineer behind this
Ryan flack and a boat and the great
directors of of Captain Marvel the years
ago they had made this movie that I
absolutely loved called Half Nelson and
I sat in for
roger ebert on say Ebert and Roeper at
the movies
to review it and stuff and blew the film
was just like these cats are amazing
this movie's astounding and years later
they made another movie that now means
it's like the world to me for completely
different reasons movies great I love
the movie I'm sorry we're not even
discussing the movie here I'll wait and
do that with mark maybe but I just
wanted to talk about the thing that
obvious obviously affected me the most
and the thing that everyone on Twitter
for the last like 72 hours before I saw
the movie was like I can't wait to see
what Gavin Smith us to say about Gavin
tomorrow everyone's being very sweet
about not spoiling it and stuff like
that but it was spoiled but it was
spoiled by the best person in the world
to [ __ ] spoil it Kevin Feige so thank
you to all those cats over Marvel man
like that [ __ ] Oscar like this
that's my legacy you kidding me they'll
be watching that [ __ ] cat Marvel
movie long after I'm out of this world
and some kid in the future some quasi
alien kid from Planet tralfazz as they
learn about Earth culture is gonna be
like you know what it what was a mall
rats mother and someone will have to go
look me up on whatever version of
Wikipedia exists may not exist if we
don't send them money this can become a
plug for Wikipedia assembly capitis
money I do everyone so I use them all
the [ __ ] time that keeps helps keep
me alive for just a little bit longer
man but more than anything else the boy
who loved movies his whole life you know
I got to make movies and stuff like that
so naturally you know I know what that's
like but this is different
like I'm inside them outside I'm inside
because like I do my movies for a living
but I'm outside like the business and
stuff like
I'm the guy they talked to you know when
they want somebody to talk about the
movies and they're like oh my god did
you like you know [ __ ] cab Marvel and
my girl of Captain Marvel so I always
feel kind of apart or outside of things
not a shitty way where I'm like [ __ ] the
I'm an outsider but just I do I always
feel kind of like well there's that
world and then there's this but for one
brief shining moment on Friday night I
like felt like oh oh they've heard of me
over there it's so stupid
anyway there it is Thank You Marvel and
Thank You Stan